[Musique]
ça y est vous le voyez autour de moi le
matériel de sons de lumières de vidéo
ressort des armoires de match event
cette entreprise spécialisée dans
l'organisation d'événements sportifs ou
culturels en tout cas dans la captation
techniques de ces événements et pour en
parler de cette reprise d'activité nous
sommes avec jean françois lienart le
cofondateur de match ivan bonjour
bonjour nicolas
on
alors avant de parler de la reprise on
va parler du bilan de cette crise
sanitaire le secteur de l'événementiel a
été frappé par cette crise comment vous
l'avez vécu ici un match event alors
c'était très dur parce que ça a été un
arrêt brutal ça a été vraiment du jour
au lendemain on se remémore le mois de
mars 2020 ça a été immédiat total en
l'espace de quinze jours tout s'est
arrêté il a fallu trouver des solutions
donc pour les collaborateurs ça tout de
suite était la mise en place du chômage
partiel et ça c'est quelque chose qui a
bien fonctionné dans notre domaine
d'activité et ensuite on a cherché des
solutions vous dire c'est pas possible
comme on reste sans rien faire del arte
le retour du confinement au mois de mai
2000 va on a eu l'idée de monter ici
vous envoyer encore les restes ici d'un
studio d'un studio digital on s'est dit
notre matériel est là y dort les clients
ont besoin de communiquer on va tenter
quelque chose on va tenter de faire
venir ici à elancourt dans notre dépôt
on a créé on a tout le matériel sur
place on s'est dit bon on est pas louer
aussi cher que si on était en événements
donc proposer à nos clients de venir
communiquer à travers l'outil qu'on
connaît tous cependant le confinement et
pendant ces deux années qui est la
visioconférence ou le streaming et on a
créé des événements digitaux vous avez
chiffré la perte que vous avez
c'est très sympa c'est un bilan par le
chiffre d'affaires c'est moins 50 %
chiffre d'affaires par an et là avec
cette reprise d'activité comment vous la
vivez cette reprise d'activité alors
elle est un petit peu elle se ressent un
petit peu comme l'arrêt elle est aussi
brutal qui a été l'arrêt c'est à dire
que les clients se sont cherchés les
annonceurs qui sont et les agences qui
sont nos clients principaux mettre du
temps à se décider et d'un seul coup on
sent qu'il ya une volonté en ce moment
de bain de se réunir parce que tout ce
qui est sanitaire était un petit peu
allégés on a le droit de se réunir à
nouveau on a le droit de refaire des
salles donc ça donne un petit peu un
élan à tout ceci
malheureusement c'est sur les chapeaux
de roue s'est tout de suite on off et
l'image qu'on voit derrière nous c'est
ça en fait voilà c'est dans la zone
exactement et dans la zone de
préparation et de est de retour donc
c'est assez de matériel qui va partir le
matériel qui rend très saine il ya déjà
été checkés et rentrer et on commence à
avoir de nouveaux enfin des poids lourds
qui partent avec du matériel avec de
l'humain et avec des clients qui sont là
physiquement l'humain c'est essentiel
dans votre métier quel élément quel type
de métier aujourd'hui vous recherchez
quelles compétences vous recherchez
aujourd'hui sur le marché du travail
alors pour répondre à la demande
croissante
on cherche une assistante comptable
parce que c'est reparti et c'est
important pour nous on cherche en
logistique 1 chauffeur poids lourd on
cherche un préparateur mettre deux
préparateurs de commande ici au niveau
des installations c'est assez ceux qui
préparent tout matériel qui le tchèque
qui vérifie que ça fonctionne pour qu'il
parte en événements on cherche qu on
appelle des régisseurs qui sont pour
nous aussi des chargés d'affaires c'est
ce qu'ils vont faire l'interface
technique entre le commercial et
et la partie technique voilà une
participante à la selle un seul
interlocuteur à ce niveau là pour nos
clients et on recherche aussi des
fonctions commerciales parce que bon on
peut pas se permettre de s'endormir sur
nos lauriers même si société qui marche
bien il faut aller chercher du new
business il faut les chercher des jeunes
talents et on est en recrutement sur ce
genre de sur ce type de poste là merci
jean françois lienart merci nicolas
cofondateur de match event et justement
on va aller tout de suite rejoindre
corinne gibourdel qui elle a été
recrutée en 2019 via un événement
organisé par l'agglomération saint
quentin en yvelines sky emploi en piste
au vélodrome monsieur
[Musique]
et
c'est la responsable communication et
création chez match event corinne
gibourdel bonjour bonjour
alors donc comme je voulais dit vous
occuper de la communication de la
création vous avez été embauchés en 2010
9 via l'événement sky emploi en piste
c'est un événement organisé par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines son principe une journée de job
dating au vélodrome national des ja
première question comment vous vous
sentez en tant que salarié d'une
entreprise du secteur de l'événementiel
aujourd'hui eh bien écoutez on a
beaucoup d'énergie non parce qu'il nous
en faut pour cette rentrée donc on est
plein d'énergie on est plein d'espoir
et on a beaucoup d'idées à mettre en
place sur les années à venir on vient de
le voir avec jean françois lienart vous
avez été frappés par la crise sanitaire
un secteur événementiel vraiment touchée
par la crise sanitaire vous comment vous
l'avez vécu cette crise sanitaire en
tant que salarié alors d'abord la
surprise évidemment comme tout le monde
tout s'arrête du jour au lendemain ce
que disait je me suis aliéna
tout où tous les tournages s'arrête le
monde s'écroule quelques pas et en même
temps où on peut pas nous se permettre
d'arrêter donc on est obligé de
continuer et c'est aussi la période sur
laquelle on va pouvoir se remettre en
question on va pouvoir entre guillemets
prendre le temps de se poser les
questions qu'on n'avait pas forcément le
temps de se poser ah bon alors on l'a vu
avec jean françois lienart vous avez des
besoins en recrutements je les ai dit au
début de l'entretien vous avez été
embauchés via l'événement sky emploi
fait sa rentrée sky emploi en piste et
justement sky emploi fait sa rentrée le
21 octobre prochain match event y
participent une journée de job dating en
virtuel est-ce que vous avez des
conseils à lui à donner aux
téléspectateurs qui souhaitent postuler
un match event et comment vous
sentiez-vous à l'époque à ce moment là
alors moi je je ne m'attendais pas à
rencontrer mon futur employeur pour être
tout à fait franc je l'étais
indépendante et je venais pour
rencontrer les entreprises pour pouvoir
retravailler avec eux mais sous forme
plutôt de mission et puis il ya eu cette
rencontre avec beaucoup de points
communs et puis une réelle envie d'aller
d'aller plus loin voilà donc c'est comme
ça qu'on a qu'on a signé ensemble donc
ça des téléspectateurs qui sont
intéressés par cet événement quels
conseils vous pouvez leur donner
aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui même
beaucoup de beaucoup d'ouverture
d'esprit beaucoup de dynamisme je pense
que ça chez match l'énergie c'est
vraiment le le point commun de tous nos
métiers on a beaucoup de métier mais ils
sont aussi de demande beaucoup de
beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup d'ouverture
beaucoup d' écoute le sens aussi du
service client c'est très important
que ce soit au niveau du conseil
clientèle pour les pour les chargés de
projet pour les assistant rh au niveau
de l'un terne mais également les
techniciens parce que parce qu'ils sont
ils sont eux mêmes aussi en contact avec
nos clients et tout ça forme un ensemble
et merci corinne gibourdel merci je
rappelle que vous êtes la responsable
communication et création chez machi 21e
sky échos se poursuit dans cette
entreprise